[Music]
it's been a year and a half since Brad
Pitt and Angelina Jolie called it quits
and now a source tells et that both are
in a better place living at their
separate lives that's life isn't it we
have challenges and you got some up
hills to face you look at your options
and you make the best decision you carry
on et's asaurus shares that Brad and
Angie are quote working to co-parent but
their divorce has not been easy adding
quote people talk about them reuniting
but it will never happen they can barely
be in the same room together and we will
always be a fit the former couples six
children is C Brad a few days a week but
live with Angelina full-time and your
children are your best friends it's kind
of it's a nice life our source says Brad
and Angie are each casually dating
non-famous people but neither is in any
sort of serious relationship though
another source tells ET brad has made a
conscious effort over the last few
months to get out more and that he has
quote in a really good place and is more
than grateful for all that he has
especially the kids
[Music]